AND YEAH
MADAM. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA. ATKINS
GORGEOUS YEAH BRADFORD HOW ADAM
CHIANG. DAO DON TORONTO CAL.
PLEASE CAN. GROVE HERTZ. HELLO
WITH SO HURTADO GEN. LEYVA
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MITCHELL.
MONNING MORE LOCK NIELSEN PAN
FOURTEEN. RALPH RUBIO I BY CAST
WIENER WELL. MEMBERS A QUORUM
IS PRESENT. MEMBERS TODAY WE
HAVE SENATOR BATES BELL GLAZER
JACKSON MORALE SKINNER AND
STERN PARTICIPATING REMOTELY SO
WE WELCOME YOU SENATORS THE
SENATORS WILL PARTICIPATE IN
THE DISCUSSION AND DEBATE BUT
WILL NOT BE PARTICIPATING IN
THE QUORUM CALL OR THE VOTE ON
MEASURES. WHAT THE MEMBERS AND
OR GET BEYOND RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE WILL BE
LEAD IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON
BY SENATOR MITCHELL AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WE WILL
BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR MONEY. GRACIOUS GOD AS
THE LATE CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS
FLIES IN STATE AT OUR UNITED
STATES CAPITAL WE REMEMBER HOW
HE DEDICATED HIS LIFE TO BRING
ABOUT RACIAL RECONCILIATION
THREE NONVIOLENCE. AND AS WE
RESUME OUR WORK IN THE MYTH OF
THE COLBERT NINETEEN EPIDEMIC.
WE HAVE A SENSE THAT WE ARE AT
THE CROSSROADS OF IN THE FUTURE.
LINKED WITH OUR PAST YET
DIFFERENT FROM IT. WE HAVE A
SENSE THAT SOMETHING IS
EIGHTEEN TO BE BORN A NEW. MANY
ARE CALLING US FORWARD. WE
TRUST THAT YOU ARE LEADING US
ON WORD. WE COMMIT TO EACH
OTHER TO ENTER DEEPLY INTO THE
RICHNESS AND COMPLEXITY OF THIS
JOURNEY. TO WALK. PATH TO LEARN
TO THE CROSS OF THE DESPERATE
AND THE DESTRUCTIVE THE
STRAIGHT AND THE STRANGE. TWO
SIX FOR ANSWERS TO QUESTIONS
THAT HAVE FOLLOWED US IN DREAMS
AND WAKING HOURS. GRACIOUS GOD
THIS TIME HELP US TO FIND NEW
WAYS TO BRING JUSTICE AND PEACE
TO THE NEW WORLD THAT BORDERS
ON OUR DOORS THIS NEW WORLD OF
GRIEF AND SORROW OF FEAR AND
ANXIETY AND YET OF TREMENDOUS
HOPE IN THE FUTURE GREATER THAN
WE COULD EVER MANAGE A MANSION.
ON IN. MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME
IN THE PLEDGE TO THE FOR. I
PLEDGE. HI THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA. AND WE HIS STANCE ONE
NATION UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE
WITH LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR
ALL. THANK YOU SO MUCH MEMBERS.
PROVIDE OF THE FLOOR THERE ARE
NOW. SINCE THIS MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DE READ.
MESSAGES FOR THE ASSEMBLY WELL
BE DEEMED READ. REPORT OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED AND
ADOPTED. MOTIONS READ. AND
NOTICE. SENATOR. UNDER MOST THE
RESOLUTION MADAM. A RESIDENT
YES MA'AM I'D LIKE TO ME TO THE
IN ACTIVE. AB SO SEVEN AND IT'S
FIVE ITEM TWENTY EIGHT. AB SO
SEVEN FILE ITEM EIGHT. SO THANK
YOU. THE FOLLOWING BILLS
REFERRED TO THE RULES COMMITTEE
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE AB TWELVE
ZERO THREE AB.
TWELVE OH THREE.
MOVING ON TO CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE SECOND READING
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE OH THREE. UHHUH.
MOVING ON TO THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS. ITEM NUMBER. FOR
SENATOR WILKES. OKAY. THANK YOU
MADAM MEBER FILE ITEM NO FOUR
SO COME FROM OF DOCTOR KELLY
PFEIFFER IS DEPUTY DIRECTOR
FROM HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
DISORDER SERVICES AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES PRIOR TO THIS
APPOINTMENT DR PLAN FOR SERVED
AS THE DIRECTOR OF HIGH VALUE
CARE AT THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION SHE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE
ON JUNE SEVENTEENTH WITH A FIVE
OH THIS FACT ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. IS THERE ANY CASH OR
DEBATE ON THIS SIDE. SAYING NOW
MADAM SECRETARY THE ROW PLEASE.
ALLEN I OUR CHILL I ATKINS I
BORDER. I BRADFORD I CAN I ADAM
I CHIANG I DALLY. I DODD. I TO
RISE. I GALGIANI. HI GONZALEZ.
GROWTH. HI HERTZBERG HI HILL HI
WITH SO. HI HER TIME. I JONES.
I LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S
I MITCHELL. I MON I MORE LAW. I
NIELSEN. I TEN I PORTS AND- I
ROSS. I RUBIO. I AM BURKE.
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WIENER. I
WILL HI. FIVE THIRTY ONE NO
ZERO THE APART IS CONFIRMED
ITEM NO FIVE SENATOR WELLS
THANK YOU YOU MAY FOR. FILE
ITEM NO FIVE A COMFORT A SHOW
REQUIRE FOR RE APPOINTMENT TO
STATE WILL RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD MISS REQUIRE IS A CIVIL
AND- WAS FIRST OF TO THE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN THE
PREVIOUS SERVICE SUPER USER AND
SECTION MANAGER FOR THE BOARD'S
DIVISION RIGHTS. HE ANIMUS.
BUYERS WE ASK FOR I LOVE. IS
THERE ANY DOES AND DEBATE.
SAYING THAT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I FORGES. BRADFORD I
HAVE A YELLOW I CHIANG HI DOLLY.
DODD I DRAWS I GALGIANI I
GONZALEZ. GROW HERTZBERG HI
HILL I WISH SO. I FOR TIME. HI
JOAN. NO LEYVA. I MCGUIRE. HI
MELINDA. NO MITCHELL. I MONNING
I MORE LAW. NIELSEN PAM I
PORTANTINO. I ROTH HI RUBIO I
I'M BURKE. WHY HOUSE SKI I
WIENER I WILK HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GORGEOUS
DALLY. GONZALEZ GROWTH I. MORE
LIKE. NIELSEN. I'M BURKE. FIVE
TWENTY FIVE KNOWS TO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. ITEM
NUMBER SIX SENATOR WILL THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX IS A CONFIRMATION OF
RICHARD RUBIN TO THE LAW
REVISION COMMISSION MR RUBIN
SUPPORT IT WAS APPROVED BY THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON THE
SEVENTEENTH OF JUNE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THERE ANY DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SAYING
NINE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I FORGES I
BRADFORD I HAVE A ITEM I CHIANG.
I DALY. NO DODD HI DORADO HI
GALGIANI HI GONZALEZ ROSE NO
HERTZBERG. I HILL HI WHERE. HI
TADO I JONES. NO LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MITCHELL.
I MONEY. I LOCK NIELSEN. PAN HI
PORTS IN. I ROTH. I READ. HI
NUMBER. WHITE HOUSE SKI I
WIENER. I WELL HI PLEASE CALL
THE UP MEMBERS. GONZALEZ. MORE
LOCK. NIELSEN NUMBER. I TWENTY
FIVE KNOWS FOR THE CAR THE
CONFIRMATION THAT. THE
APPOINTMENTS ARE CONFIRMED ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN SENATOR WILKES
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
REPRESENTS FILE ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN WHICH IS A CONFIRMATION
OF ARTHUR ANDERSEN TO THE BOARD
OF PAROLE HEARINGS MISTER
ANDERSON HAS SERVED AS A PAROLE
BOARD COMMISSIONER SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT. PRIOR TO
THAT HE SERVED AS A LIEUTENANT
CHIEF AND ASSISTANT
COMMISSIONER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE BILLS.
THERE ANY THIS TO BE ON THIS I.
SAYING THAT SECRETARY CALL ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I
FORGES. BRADFORD I HAVE A ADAM.
I CHIANG. TEN DOW. DODD I THERE
I WASN'T I GALGIANI. I GONZALEZ
GROWTH. HERTZ I HILL AYE WITH.
I TITLE I JONES. LEYVA I WIRE I
MELINDA'S. MITCHELL I MONEY I
MORE LOCK NIELSEN. PAN I
PORTANTINO I ROTH. I RUBIO. HI
I'M BURKE WHITE HOUSE SKI AYE
WIENER. I WILK. HI PLEASE CALL
THE MEMBERS. FOR JUST I CHIANG.
DALLY. GONZALEZ. GROVE. JONES
MELENDEZ. MORE LOCK. NIELSEN.
I'M BURKE. FIVE TWENTY FOUR NO
ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED. ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
SENATOR WELLS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT IS A CONFIRMATION OF
PATRICIA CASSIDY RANDOLPH
GROUNDS AND MICHAEL ROUGH TO
THE BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS
THESE COMMISSIONERS WERE
APPROVED BY THE SENATE RULES
COMMITTEE ON THE SEVENTEENTH OF
JUNE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE THOSE. THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SAYING NINE MADAM
SECRETARY THE ROLE PLEASE.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
PORGES AYE BRADFORD I HAVE A
YELLOW I CHIANG AYE DOLLY. I
DODD. HI THERE I WASN'T. I
GALGIANI. HI GONZALEZ GROSS I
HERTZBERG HI HELLO HI WAY SOON.
HI TODD I JACK JONES. I LEYVA.
HI REQUIRE HI MELENDEZ I
MITCHELL I MONEY. I MORE LOCK I
NIELSEN. I PAN. FIVE FOUR. HI
HI ROSS. I RUBIO. I AM BURKE.
WHITE HOUSE SKI. BIRDS THAT
COMPLETES THE CONSIDERATION OF
THE DAILY FILE. BACK TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS. SENATOR
MITCHELL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISS MADAM PRESIDENT I MOVE
JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO AB WAVED
FOR THE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE TO MEET ON
THURSDAY JULY. WHAT FOUR DAYS
IN THE DAILY FOR. RECOGNIZING
CENTER JONES THANK YOU MADAM-PRESIDENT TURNER STANDING THAT
THIS BILL IS STILL IN INTENT
FORM SO WE OBJECTION THE MOTION
ASK FOR ROLL CALL THE. SO
ORDERED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BOARD.
NO BRADFORD I HAVE A ADAM I
CHIANG. NO DALLY. NO DODD. I
THE RISER I GALGIANI I GONZALEZ.
GROSS NO HERTZBERG. HI HILL I
HUESO. I TADO I JONES. NO LEYVA.
I WILL GO. I MELENDEZ NO
MITCHELL I. HI MORE LOCK. NO
NIELSEN. PAN HI PORTANTINO. I
ROTH. HI RUBIO I NUMBER. WHITE
HOUSE SKI HI WIENER. HI WELL.
NO I TWENTY TWO KNOWS EIGHT THE
MOTION PASSES. SEEING NO
FURTHER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
SENATOR BRADFORD. SENATOR
BRADFORD YOU HAVE AN INTERN IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I STAND HERE TODAY
ASKING FOR THIS AUGUST BODY TO
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF. JOHN
ROBERT LOUIS AN AMERICAN ICON A
PUBLIC SERVANT TO THE HIGH
SIXTEEN INDIVIDUAL WHO.
DEMONSTRATED ON A DAILY BASIS
THAT LOVE WILL CONQUER ALL THE
EVIL IN THE WORLD I INDIVIDUAL
WHO WHEN YOU LOOK AROUND AND
YOU LOOK AT THE BLACK LIVES
MATTER AND ALL THE YOUTH IN
THIS COUNTRY THAT ARE ACTIVATED
IT WAS THROUGH HIS EXAMPLE. AS
A NINETEEN YEAR OLD. WHO WENT
TO. GEORGIA AND GOT INVOLVED IN
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT WITH
DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER KING HAD A
TEENAGER MANY TIMES WE
ATTRIBUTE. WELL LIKE MARTIN
LUTHER KING AND- RALPH
ABERNATHY AND- JULIAN BOND IN
INDIVIDUALS LIKE THAT FOR THE
CITY AND BUT IT WAS THE YOUNG
FOLKS WHO REALLY SAT DOWN. JOHN
LEWIS. SAT DOWN FOR US TO STAND
UP. JOHN LEWIS STOOD UP. SO WE
COULD ENTER PLACES THAT WE
COULD GO BEFORE. JOHN LEWIS WAS
ARRESTED OVER FORTY TIMES IN
HIS LIFE. DURING PEACEFUL
PROTEST SIMILAR TO THE ONES
THAT WE SEE TODAY AND IT'S
SOMEWHAT SAT BACK SOME OF THE
FEDERAL RESPONSE IS SIMILAR TO
WHAT WE SAW IN THE SIXTIES
SUPPOSED TO WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
THE CROSSING IN NINETEEN SIXTY
THREE OF THE EDMUND PETTUS
BRIDGE WHERE JOHN LEWIS. CAME
WITHIN INCHES OF LOSING HIS
LIFE THIS CALL WAS CRUSHED. BY
BILLY CLUB BY STATE TROOPERS
THE SAME STATE TROOPERS WHO
YESTERDAY ESCORTED HIS CASKET.
AND HIS- HIS COFFIN ANA ACROSS
THAT MEANT PETTUS BRIDGE A
SYMBOLISM OF. THE MOVEMENT AND
THE GROWTH IN THIS COUNTRY BUT
THERE'S STILL MUCH TO DO. I'M
HONORED TO HAVE MET MISTER
LEWIS DURING THE COURSE OF MY
LIFE. WE WERE FRATERNITY
BROTHERS WERE PROUD MEMBERS OF
PHI BETA SIGMA FRATERNITY. AND
I WAS ALWAYS. HONOR TO INTERACT
WITH THEM AND YOU ALWAYS CALL
ME MY BROTHER SO I'M HONOR TO
HAVE SERVED THROUGH A
FRATERNITY OF FRATERNAL ORDER
WITH MISTER LEWIS BUT I'M MORE
HONOR TO HAVE MET SOMEONE. WHO
LIVED A LIFE OF LOVE. OF
GENEROSITY A INDIVIDUAL WHO HAD
THE COURAGE OF A WARRIOR. THE
FIERCENESS OF A WARRIOR BUT OUR
HEART OF AN ANGEL. A MAN WHO
GOOD FOR DO YOU HAVE THE KKK.
INDIVIDUAL WHO NEARLY BEAT HIM
TO DEATH SOME FORTY YEARS LATER
THEY MATT AND HIS OFFICE IN
WASHINGTON DC AND NOT ONLY THE
FORGIVEN HE HUGGED ON ANY SAYS
I LOVE YOU MY BROTHER. THAT TO
JOHN LEWIS WAS THAT TWO YEARS
AND WE SHOULD ALL STRIVE TO
MAKE THIS COUNTRY A BETTER
PLACE. I INDIVIDUAL AGAIN WHO
STOOD FOR CIVIL RIGHTS. VOTING
RIGHTS BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY THE
HUMAN RIGHTS I ASKED THE OUIJA
EARN IN HONOR OF JOHN LEWIS.
AND. MADAM PRO THANK YOU AN
IMPRESSIVE TELL A SEVERAS TO
MEN OF A LOVED NATIONAL YOU REP
JOHN ROBERT LOUIS. CONGRESSMAN
LEWIS WAS TRUE A RIGHT FORCE
AND ARE REAL FIGHT FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS IN LIBERTY. FROM
LEADERSHIP DURING THE SUNDAY
MARCH ACROSS THE EDMUND PETTUS
BRIDGE IN SELMA. HAVING
CHAMPION THE EQUALITY ACT TO
END DISCRIMINATION AGAINST LGBT
Q. AMERICANS. CONGRESSMAN LEWIS
TAUGHT US WHAT BRAVERY LOOK
LIKE A NEVER HESITATED IN HIS
PURSUIT LIBERTY AT HIS DECADES
OF SERVICE. HE ALSO NEVER
STOPPED AND- FUTURE GENERATIONS
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN HE CAME TO
COMIC CON IN SAN DIEGO AND
COSPLAY HIMSELF SPORTING A
JACKET. AND A BACKPACK LIKE THE
ONES HE WORE WHEN HE LED THE
MARCH ACROSS THE BRIDGE TO
MONTGOMERY ALABAMA. ALTHOUGH
KING A TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLD
VERSION OF HIMSELF HE LED A
GROUP OF CHILDREN IN A MARCH.
THROUGH THE CONVENTION CENTER
SHOWING THEM THAT YOU DON'T
NEED A CAKE OR SUPER POWERS TO
BE A HERO. P. DID THAT TRIP AND
THE MARCH THE FOLLOWING TWO
YEARS. HE WAS AN INSPIRATION TO
ME AND TO ALL WHO BELIEVE TRUE
EQUALITY IS A CALL IS WORTHY OF
SACRIFICE AND HIS LEGACY
REMAINS A BEACON OF HOPE FOR
ALL WHO CHAMPION JUSTICE. WE
GRIEVE THE LOSS OF CONGRESSMAN
LEWIS AND WE CARRY HIS WISDOM
AND ENERGY FORWARD AS WE
CONTINUE TO PURSUE EQUALITY
INCLUSIVITY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
SENATOR DRAWS A. FROM I NEED TO
ALSO INCLUDE IN ALL OF THE
WORDS THAT WE'RE ALL SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF CONGRESSMAN LEWIS
IS THE ROLE THAT HE PLAYED IN
RAISING THE PROFILE AND THE
NEED TO INCLUDE THE RIGHTS OF
IMMIGRANTS IN OUR STRUGGLES
HERE IN THIS IN THIS COUNTRY IN
TWO THOUSAND THREE WE DID THE
IMMIGRANT WORKERS FREEDOM RIDE.
COURSE IN HONOR NOT OF RESPECT
FOR WHAT THE FREEDOM. RIDERS
HAD DONE A DECADES BEFORE- AND
HE DID NOT HESITATE- TO BECOME
OF THE NATIONAL CO CHAIR ALONG
WITH REVEREND JAMES LAWSON- SO
I AM. PERSONALLY AND DEEPLY-
INDEBTED FOR THE ROLE THAT HE
PLAYED. AND JUST A FEW YEARS
AGO- I THINK RECENTLY IN THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS HE ALSO
GOT ARRESTED- IN WASHINGTON DC
ON ISSUES OF IMMIGRANTS RIGHTS
AS HUMAN RIGHTS SO. WE ALSO-
HONOR HIS ROLE IN THIS NATION
FOR ALL PEOPLE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR THOSE. INTERNET
MEMORIES PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO HE CAN BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED BY
THE SENATE. IF THERE IS NO
OTHER BUSINESS SENATOR ACTIONS
THE DESK IS CLEAR THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I
RISE TO EXTEND MY GRATITUDE TO
ALL OF YOU AND CERTAINLY MY
APOLOGIES. THE CODE NINETEEN
CRISIS IS PLACED US IN A
SITUATION THAT NONE OF US WOULD
HAVE HOPED FOR AND CERTAINLY
NOT WHAT WE ENVISIONED WHEN
SESSION BEGAN THIS YEAR. BUT
WE'RE MEETING THE DEMANDS OF
THE CONSTRAINED CALENDAR AND
THE VERY CHALLENGING STRUCTURE.
IF TWENTY TWENTY WERE A NORMAL
YEAR WE WOULD BE WATCHING AND
CELEBRATING OUR ATHLETES
COMPETING IN THE OLYMPICS. I
KNOW WE WISH THEM ALL THE BEST
AS THEY CONTINUE TO TRAIN AND
TO WORK TO REALIZE THEIR
DREAMS. AND I LIKE TO REMEMBER
HOW MUCH THEY'RE SACRIFICING.
AS IT HELPS PUT INTO
PERSPECTIVE THE THOUGHT OF
DELAYING. MY BILLS MANY OF YOU
HAVE DELAYED YOURS AND OTHER
PROJECTS. HEY AT LEAST WE HAVE
BASEBALL TO NOW LIFT OUR
SPIRITS. BUT I WANT TO THANK
YOU ON A SERIOUS NOTE I WANT TO
THANK YOU OFFER UNDERSTANDING
FOR THE HARD WORK THAT YOU ALL
OF YOUR STAFFS. AND OUR
COMMITTEE STAFFS HAVE
CONTRIBUTED. I ALSO WANT TO
THANK SECRETARY CONTRAIRE US
AND HURTING TIRE TEAM. WHO'S
BEEN WORKING NONSTOP TO HELP US
RETURN SAFELY AND WITH THE
TOOLS THAT WE NEED TO KEEP
MOVING FORWARD. AS YOU KNOW THE
CIRCUMSTANCES CHANGE QUICKLY
AND WILL ALWAYS MAKE SURE THAT
YOU'RE KEPT UP TO DATE. AND YOU
COULD CALL MY OFFICE WITH ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE I
WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
DETERMINATION AND DEDICATION TO
THE PEOPLE'S WORK. WE HAVE SOME
HARD WORK AHEAD OF US THESE
NEXT FIVE WEEKS BUT I KNOW THAT
TOGETHER WE WILL EMERGE FROM
THIS CHALLENGE STRONGER THAN
EVER BEFORE. AND WITH THAT
MADAM PRESIDENT WE WILL OUR
HAVE FLOOR SESSION ON THURSDAY
JULY THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT NINETY EIGHT EVERYONE BE
SAFE AND WELL. OFF THIS WEEK AS
YOU CONDUCT THE COMMITTEE WORK
THAT YOU'RE DOING AND I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THE SENATE WILL
BE A RECESS UNTIL THREE PM. AT
WHICH TIME THE ENGER MOTION
WILL BE PLACED WE WILL
RECONVENE AS INDICATED ON
THURSDAY AT NINE AM. BE SAFE
EVERYONE.